soon the park doors to Jurassic world
will open so let's step back to where it
all began
welcome to Jurassic Park Jurassic Park
is the coolest most epic theme park
we've ever seen everyone would buy a
ticket to this part but how could a park
like this be built how expensive would
it be join us as we break down the
financial costs of a live dinosaur
themed park to figure out how much would
it cost to build Jurassic Park Jurassic
Park is funded by the Engine Corporation
a genetics research company founded and
owned by billionaire John Hammond to
build Jurassic Park Hammond first needed
some tropical real estate we know from
the movies that their site a where the
park was built and site B where the
dinosaurs were raised both these islands
are off the coast of Costa Rica
according to Costa Rican real estate
websites two islands at a total land
size of 66 square miles would be worth
about 10 billion dollars Jurassic Park
would require a very special staff the
park would employ scientists
paleontologists animal caretakers
computer engineers a legal team and more
putting together a team of each of these
jobs we get a price of about 7.9 million
dollars the science behind cloning the
dinosaurs requires some special costs
bio arts a california-based company that
clones people's dogs which charge
$150,000 to clone a dog we will multiply
that number by 50 because of the 50
different dinosaurs in the park also
we'll add the cost of surrogates embryo
development stem-cell research and gene
modification which gets us to eight
point five million dollars to get the
dinosaur DNA we need mosquitoes trapped
in prehistoric amber the mine we see in
the beginning of the film is a small
operation full of low paid workers using
shovels and flashlights to acquire
enough amber for proper extraction would
require several minds sure you can
always get amber at those roadside
souvenir stands but legitimate
production expenses add up to nine
million dollars research and development
25 million four hundred thousand dollars
all Jurassic park's physical assets such
as the cool Jeeps
the t-rex paddocks the visitor center
and the electric fences will fit into
this category to find a real-world cost
of the construction of Jurassic Park we
looked into the construction budgets of
some of the biggest amusement parks in
the world the average construction price
for the world's biggest theme parks is
1.5 billion dollars Park construction
1.5 billion dollars we looked into real
world parks for financial breakdowns of
their operations according to public
fiscal reports the Disney parks division
of the Walt Disney Company spends a
total of eleven point seven
a year in operating expenses that comes
to thirty two million dollars each day
to run the parks park operations eleven
point seven billion dollars a year
caring for a real-life dinosaur can not
be cheap we figured the cost of feed
groom and nurture the Jurassic Park
dinosaurs is about the same as a very
large zoo one of the largest zoos in the
world is the famous San Diego Zoo they
have 3,700 animals representing more
than 650 species according to the public
fiscal reports of the San Diego Zoo they
spent about 207 million dollars a year
in operating expenses that's about five
hundred fifty thousand six hundred
eighty four dollars a day to run the zoo
dinosaur livelihood two hundred seven
million dollars a year add up these
enormous prices and we get a grand total
of twenty three billion four hundred
thirty two million four hundred thousand
dollars and annual repeating costs of 11
billion nine hundred seven million
dollars however we did forget to
calculate how much it would cost to
clean up all that Dino poop that is one
big pile of [ __ ] we'd rather not get our
hands into that mess
you